Republican Senator Lindsey Graham is
with us from the Capitol Senator Graham
good morning good morning
you are quoted as saying that you
thought that the opening statement by
James Comey was a good thing a good day
you said a pretty good day for the
president right why'd you say it well
number one and the statement Comey said
that the president is not a target or
subject to an investigation
counterintelligence criminal or
otherwise regarding Russian collusion as
of this moment now something may happen
later but as of right now this moment
president's not under investigation for
colluding with Russia and unless Muller
is a complete idiot which he is not
he's concluded there's no obstruction
justice case because if he had concluded
otherwise Comey wouldn't be testifying
you wouldn't let your chief and only
witness go through this process if you
really believe you believed you had a
case to prosecute and mr. Muller is a
good process atom shift on this program
this morning said I would have to
strongly disagree with my colleague
Lindsey Graham proactive Bob Muller it's
not worried about his testifying I think
that does not suggest anything about how
Bob Muller views the case indeed it
would be astonished if he had a view
this early that's crazy
chicken educator no chips not crazy the
analysis is crazy
I've been a prosecutor defense attorney
and a military judge nobody in their
right mind who believed they had a case
would take their star witness and allow
them to go before the nation and 20
senators you just don't do it that way
so he's concluded I think rightly
there's no obstruction of justice here
to think otherwise really is silly and
at the end of the day commies actions
tend to suggest that he didn't believe
the president Eric Ross senator is it
okay for the President of the United
States to invite the FBI director for a
private dinner ask him does he want his
job and then say to him I need your
loyalty is that okay to do no out of
half of what Trump does is not okay if
you're trying to convict him for being
bull in a china shop crude and rude
you'd win I mean you know no this is for
you doesn't that
for you and I think that a lot of us
stuff troubles me but it's not a crime
yeah the question is not about crew
durood the question is about not only
appropriateness but legality and let me
ask you this
James Comey and his testimony
specifically accuses the president of
asking him to drop the investigation
against Michael Flynn right the
President himself was asked about this
on May 18th in the White House in a
joint press er where he was asked did
you in any way shape or form ask to
close down the investigation into
Michael Flynn the president responded no
no who do you believe is line the former
FBI director or the President of the
United States well I think if you look
at commis statement they he said well
maybe he had a different view of this
and I did I think what Trump was trying
to do is help Flynn because he thought
he had already been punished enough but
you also got to remember that Comey
under oath on May the 3rd testified
there was no pressure interference
applied to this investigation about
anyone anyone that was before he's fired
now that he's been fired as a different
story detail but here's the deal when
Comey was asked under oath has anybody
tried to interfere with this
investigation he said no the the story
described by Comey is disturbing it
wasn't appropriate by the President to
put him in this situation
so the question is what would be
necessary in your eyes hope to take what
we already know and make it obstruction
of justice for the FBI director acted
consistent with it being obstructing
justice by going to the Department of
Justice reporting a crime resigning or
pursuing charges there's no way you'll
ever convince me that the FBI director
the top of the legal chain thought this
was obstruction of justice because if he
had thought that he would have done
something differently so based on what
you know you see no obstruction of
justice I don't see obstruction of
justice I don't see any collusion by
Trump you know Trump can't collude with
his own government so I doubt if he's
colluding with the Russians so here's
the deal
keep looking find out what's out there I
think what bothers me the most about
President Trump in Russia is his
weakened naive response to Russia's
interference in our
he seems to have a view of Putin is
disconnected from everybody else in
Washington and that really bothers me
but let this investigation go forward
let Muller go forward but I want to tell
your audience in my mind there is no
evidence of collusion if you don't
believe me ask call me and there's no
way this is obstruction of justice
because Muller what light and testament
let me ask you this senator do you
believe there was an effort by the
Russians to compromise the incoming
president in other words we learn from
this opening - yeah we learn from this
opening testimony the James Comey first
met Donald Trump at January 6th at Trump
Tower in which he talked about this
salacious and unfair affair and verified
document he said he went because the
head of the DNI said I should meet with
him one-on-one privately tell him that
they have this stuff in him and they may
use it to in his words compromise an
incoming president is that gonna stream
yeah I saw that document long before it
was you're talking about it was given to
Senator McCain and I looked at it and I
said oh wow but here you know this Trump
fever you know people say why are you
defending Trump I've been getting really
suspicious of all things Russia here the
details of that document haven't been
corroborated as of this day we now know
nobody can prove that Trump colluded
with the Russians and represented to
ship Assad I believe that Muller would
not let Comey come forward if he
believed this was obstruction of justice
now the business ties I've been
suspicious about the Trump world in
Russia financing I have yet to see
anything let's keep looking and if I
were the president I'd get back to
governing but from a legal point of view
I think Comey has probably helped the
president from a political point of view
he's in a box most Americans don't trust
him on Russia 70% of the people don't
believe that he's telling the truth
about Russia and that's going to hurt
the president the best thing he could do
is push back against Putin and realize
that the mess you're in mr. president is
caused by Putin's interference in our
election he's providing arms to the
Taliban he aided and abetted Assad's
chemical attack against young children
that made you so mad you misjudging
Putin Thank You senators great to have
you great time thank you